hi i'm christine goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
the democratic national convention has
come to an end
did presidential nominee joe biden and
the party make a strong case to the
american people
fox news radio's national correspondent
jared halpern and fox news radio's
political analyst josh crushauer
recapped the key moments
with former tennessee congressman harold
ford jr
and he attended his first presidential
convention as a teenager in 1964.
now 56 years later fox news sunday host
chris wallace has covered plenty of
campaigns
but none he says like the current race
to the white house
so what makes 2020 different the anchor
explains why he thinks this election
season
will only continue to get stranger and
weighs in on the controversy
surrounding early voting plus commentary
by former utah congressman
and fox news contributor jason chaffetz
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we take a deeper look at
the stories important
to you you can subscribe on your
favorite podcast
player by going to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm brian kilmeade i'm martha mccallum
i'm david asman and this
is the fox news rundown
friday august 21st 2020
i'm jared halpern joe biden accepts the
democratic nomination for president with
a promise
to unite the country joe biden gave us a
real sense of how he would lead and
frankly why he's running
i'm chris foster election day is
november 3rd but with more early and
mail-in voting expected especially this
year
fox news sunday host chris wallace says
the candidates have less time than usual
to make their case
we don't have an election day anymore we
have an election season
and you know from mid-september on
people are voting and i'm jason chaffetz
i've got the final word
on the fox news rundown
[Music]
joe biden is the democratic nominee for
president
accepting his party's nomination to wrap
up the first political convention of its
kind
done virtually for biden his acceptance
speech was
decades in the making he has ran for
president twice before
first in 1988 again in 2008 neither time
approaching the support
needed to claim the nomination this year
looked like he could fall short again
after distant finishes and early contest
in iowa in new hampshire
biden had a primary winning streak start
in south carolina
in super tuesday and then never looked
back
this week several of his former rivals
offered enthusiastic speeches of support
attempting to unify the democratic party
joe biden and kamala harris know the
dignity of all working americans
they know the urgency and the demand of
our dream
i trust joe biden and kamala harris to
guide us toward that better future
because i've seen up close their empathy
if you feel stuck in the middle of the
extremes in our politics
if you are tired of the noise and the
nonsense you have a home with me
and you have a home with joe biden while
joe
and i disagree on the best path
to get universal coverage he has a plan
that will greatly expand health care joe
and kamala will make high quality child
care affordable for every family
in his address thursday night biden said
he'll now unite
the country here and now i give you my
word
if you entrust me with the presidency i
will draw on the best of us not the
worst
i'll be an ally of the light not the
darkness
mixing his own personal tragedies with
the politics of the moment
biden also singled out americans who
have lost loved ones to the coronavirus
pandemic
i know how mean and cruel and unfair
life can be sometimes
but i've learned two things first
your loved one may have left this earth
but they'll never leave your heart
they'll always be with you you'll always
hear them
and second i found the best way through
pain and loss and grief
is to find purpose as god's children
each of us have a purpose in our lives i
thought it was uplifting i thought it
was
was rich with substance harold ford jr
served in congress for a decade
as a democrat representing the memphis
area he also delivered the keynote
address at the democratic national
convention in 2000
the congressman joined me and fox news
political analyst josh cross
our on the message democrats delivered
this week
in the campaign it sets up in the fall i
thought it was
was overall the kind of speech he needed
to give and the kind of speech that puts
him on a path to
you know to being ready to to do the
kind of unorthodox campaigning he's
going to do in the fall about that i
mean
unorthodox for that i mean it's not
going to be a traditional
rally holding campaign rally for for for
either of the candidates so i'll be
probably some of that but not what we
are
we're used to in a fall campaign so
overall i thought it was
was was was good for him good for the
country and
and i expect president trump next week
will have a good good convention as well
we'll probably
deliver a you know equally equally
strong message as well and
we'll be off to the races of the country
and also the races as they uh
uh i should say that campaigns will be
off to the races starting next week so
over the last four nights we saw the
democratic party really sort of
try and tell a few stories i felt a very
united front with the different factions
after a very contentious primary coming
together
but you also saw the party spend a lot
of time over the last few nights talking
about
uh for instance the black lives matter
movement racial justice
the environment the green new deal uh
talking about uh the these these social
issues
and i'm just curious you delivered the
keynote address at the dnc what in the
year 2000 right
correct so over the last 20 years
is the democratic party that was
displayed this week the same democratic
party you addressed
back then in 2000 well i think in some
parts yeah
and other parts no it's the same party
the standpoint that it believes in
the the beauty bounty and power of the
country and the power of the promise of
the experiment of the country
which is um you know you believe in
people you believe in
opportunity but you believe in justice
we believe in the the fact that any and
every person regardless of their
background
regardless of how they look have an
opportunity to succeed
um i think the republican party is has
gone through changes
you know and it reflects where the
country is
in a lot of ways as well but the the
core
of of who the party is and who the party
believes and who the party wants to
represent i don't think it's changed uh
has changed in many ways uh at all
you know i went to college uh with bo
biden
boy and our friends were actually close
friends at penn
and the the party that that that existed
then
and the kind of things that we stood up
for and believed that on campus at penn
beau and so many of our classmates back
then you know a lot of ways the
democratic party
uh reflects that and and and the biggest
and proudest of ways uh the country's is
is different though in a lot of ways i
mean i think about when i was 18 i'm now
50 uh and and and when we started out as
freshmen beau was a year ahead of me
um what what the country what the
country looked like and what the country
which was
was trying to succeed with and what the
country was trying to
to do better with we're still trying to
do those things but
you know we've had 9 11 occur we've had
a financial crisis that we've gone
through
a whole other litany of things in and
around those times and obviously what
we've gone through in just the last six
months seven months as a country
uh or less it's hard to hardly imagine
it's been since
march and just trying to keep track of
the last five months what we've gone
through
so and i think both parties are having
to adjust
and and the democratic party has i think
in so many ways stay true to whom it is
and
uh or what it is and and it has tried
its hardest to figure out how do you
represent the
the least the vulnerable the smallest
and middle class in the country and
i thought joe biden's speech was
representative of that in many many ways
congressman there was a line in joe
biden's speech that really stuck with me
talking about
his dad who was a used car salesman he
used to say
joey i don't expect the government to
solve my problems but i sure in hell
expect them to understand them
that sounded like almost a throat like a
throwback to the clinton years where
government is going to do everything but
it needs to be empathetic it needs to be
compassionate
uh almost like compassionate
conservatism of the bush years
did you get any message of how joe biden
views government how ideologically you
think he would govern as president if
he's elected
sure i mean there's the context of that
obviously is
is the kind of pull and tug in the party
right now i think between
you know some who expect government to
or
or believe that governments should do
just about
everything and some will believe that
government has to do a lot and
if you do a lot people can do a lot more
uh but
i i listened to that line and i thought
about clint i wasn't
listening to listening to the president
listen to president clinton talk about
um you know the role of government and
the the
the limits of government and i think one
of the things that
that voters are thinking about in a big
big way you know
based on how the rhetoric in this
campaign has has evolved up to this
point from both sides from president
trump
and and from vice president biden it's
very simple i mean how
how far do you expect government to go
and and and whether or not the character
of our nation which is
a lot of what the republicans for
largely what president trump is accusing
democrats of
of of taking us down the path of
socialism i thought that
first of all i disagree with that and i
think vice president biden
clearly demonstrated that um that that
will not be the case about the fall and
then the debate that we're going to have
when i say the fall i mean the kind of
conversation we'll have in the fall
between two candidates
will be you know rest upon and
predicated upon who has a better
set of ideas about how to make
government work
and government work and the most
effective and
in the smartest and and frankly most
limited of ways
while at the same time benefiting the
country and benefiting families and
not ignoring that we've gone through a
pandemic something that
that that has really reset and shifted
our economy
and our lives and our livelihoods and
our health care and education every
other aspect of american life
has caused us to think very differently
about how things
uh how things will go how things will
progress going forward and how
government has to think about
its role going forward so i like you i
thought a lot about that line and i hope
that it resonates with americans not
just with us
but with voters across the country i
wanted to finish on this note
congressman since we just watched
a convention unlike any convention we've
ever seen before
um obviously because of what's required
with the coronavirus pandemic and i just
want to get your thoughts on on what you
thought of the presentation and if you
think
this may be what conventions look
more like in the next four eight sixteen
however many years
watching watching this convention
like a lot of america took a minute to
get used to the first night
and the second night third night even
tonight but there were parts of it i
enjoyed more it moved faster
uh you you could you were allowed to
hear and see more speakers you missed
the pageantry of being there and the
energy in the uh in the arena
or a convention or the convention hall
or even the city afterwards and and you
know leading up to it all of the
the back and forth and the opportunity
to sit down and and you know meet with
people
one of my great mentors uh in politics
is richard holbrooke and i can remember
at the convention in boston sitting with
him and in the morning to breakfast
uh for a little bit before he would
commence his his marathon of meetings uh
on those days
uh but there was so many you meet with
but i gotta tell you i think the
democrats did a good job i
imagine the republicans will will learn
from this this week and and try their
hardest to pull it off as well and i
hope they
i wish them the very best as they as
they go about it
uh but i gotta say i i miss the the
interactions
and the and the being around people if
we have to do this
or this becomes some part of it or
become some
you know something about what we just
experienced becomes a
significant part of how conventions are
done i guess i'll get used to it but
i never thought i'd say i'm
old-fashioned at 50 years old but i i do
miss the
and didn't miss being there and and
seeing friends i mean it's a time to
sort of the the playoffs in super bowl
uh politics
i gotta tell you i'm one that hopes that
we can get back to the
in person and face the face of uh of the
convention one day
and congressman i understand how you
feel i i always referred to it
as political sleep-away camp it's always
a fun time
for guys like us to get around and just
sort of like live and breathe politics
for the whole week
uh harold ford jr former congressman
from the great state of tennessee
appreciate the time
be well yeah well josh i gotta tell you
i read your piece
on on and i read a lot of pieces but i
read your piece on
how democrats organized this thing
around against donald trump and they've
got organ and energized people around it
i thought it was a great piece i agree
with you but i thought uh
joe biden gave us a a real sense of how
he would lead and and frankly why he's
running and
and hopefully donald trump does the same
next week and we're
we'll be off to the races to a serious
contest of ideas here in the next the
next several weeks so
thank you guys for having me on thanks
guys thank you very much
we'll see you soon take care
[Music]
this is jason chaffetz with your fox
news commentary
coming up chris wallace attended his
first presidential convention as a
teenager in 1964
hired as an assistant to cbs evening
news anchor walter cronkite
he saw barry goldwater nominated by the
republicans that year then lose to
president lyndon johnson
he has of course since grown up to cover
several presidential campaigns and
conventions himself since 2003
as the host of fox news sunday nobody's
ever seen one like what the democrats
just held and the republicans will be
holding next week during the coronavirus
pandemic
it felt more like a telethon uh and
those can be
kind of interesting for a while and then
and then not so interesting but looking
at it from
30 000 feet what strikes me is
that this convention has has spent a lot
of time
talking about all the reasons why
uh donald trump has disqualified himself
from
having a second term it's talked a lot
about how the country
can't take it for granted and that
people who didn't vote
in in 2016 because they thought hillary
was going to win
uh need to get out and vote what what
the country
i mean what the convention i think
lacked is a kind of
animating philosophy other than kind of
a return to normalcy after the four
trump years
and any kind of what the theme is
about and the big idea is of a biden
presidency i look back to
92 with bill clinton when it was a kind
of new
more centrist democratic uh philosophy
uh in 2008 hope and change and yes we
can
and you know a new generation taking
over the country
um i don't know maybe you you've got an
idea chris but
what is the big idea other than he won't
be donald trump
that's i think pretty much what i've
heard uh i mean i haven't measured this
out just my gut
from watching what i've watched is that
for every biden mention you get two or
three trump mentions and then maybe
another mention of hey you have to go
out there and vote
uh we've had some gop involvement maybe
more than usual you always get one or
two but you know john kasich cindy
mccain the message to republicans seems
to be
hey look you have permission this time
to vote for
joe biden he's okay do you think it'll
work
well yeah i think it'll work for some
people there are a lot of
republicans i mean if you look at the
numbers in
when when people are polled it's 80 90
percent of republicans
uh support donald trump but there
certainly is a percentage
my guess is didn't vote for hillary
clinton last time uh
who have turned away from president
trump and and they're very important i
mean if you get
uh some college educated
uh whites if you get suburban women uh
who are often in the republican camp
uh they you know if they if they switch
and don't just sit home but actually
vote for joe biden
that could make a difference in in a lot
of states for instance pennsylvania with
all the suburbs
around uh philadelphia so i mean it it
could have an impact
uh we'll have to wait and see uh
and and also and this is uh something
you certainly heard a lot from barack
obama
trying to get minorities who who didn't
transfer
the the affection and the support and
getting out to vote
uh of they felt for barack obama for
hillary clinton the minority turnout was
quite a lot smaller and
particularly in a couple of those key
swing states that went
like pennsylvania like michigan that
ended up going for trump so
you know you don't have to make huge
changes uh
but if you're able to get some people
who didn't vote to switch
or some people did vote to switch some
people who didn't vote to actually vote
that can have a big difference
i feel like we lost a few weeks
somewhere this summer i blinked and the
election's 74 days away i feel like it
just was a hundred and now today it's 70
and now it's going to be 74. although by
this time next month
seven states will have already started
early voting or they're going to be at
least getting the mail-in ballots in
people's mailboxes and election day
itself is going to mean a lot less than
ever this year
yeah i mean we don't have an election
day anymore we have an election
season and you know from mid-september
on
uh people are voting and that is
certainly something i think that
democrats have done very effectively
in this speech and you and i thought
while he didn't talk a lot about biden
obama talked a lot about mobilizing sort
of like the community organizer he once
was
and a lot of talk you're hearing and
even uh
you know i i've heard it so often i
memorize it texting 30330
you know to find out what the rules are
in your state and
telling people to vote early uh and and
you know don't let your vote get taken
away i i do think they've been effective
in that
in talking about voters oppression and
that it's on
each individual who's watching this
convention
to get out and and avoid that by by
voting early
and not allowing uh kinks in the system
particularly
with mail-in voting with with the
problems with the post office
to get in the way i think they've done a
good job of that whatever you think
about possible shenanigans
with the postal service vis-a-vis the
election
uh part of the problem here is just
state-by-state rules where the
turnaround time between ballot requests
and returns by election day is just so
short in some places that the post
office may just physically not be able
to
get it turned back around in time so
that's right and
and and you're hearing a bunch of states
uh
that are talking about if it's
postmarked
by november 3rd election day you know
they'll be counting votes for another
week to 10 days after you know i i'm
not smart enough to be a member of the
fox news decision desk
but i don't know how you how you make
calls and say
so and so has won this state when you
don't
know what what percentage of people you
know usually we say
uh 78 of precincts reporting in
well we're not going to know that
because we're not going to know how many
people in that precinct
didn't go to the polls and but did mail
in a ballot which may have
may not even get to uh the the election
centers until two days after the
election and may not get counted for a
week so
it's going to be a very unique and
different
uh fall campaign season and i think
you know election night could well turn
into election week
yeah i think we're going to have to
educate our audiences about
the fact that look this call may not
come unless it's an absolute just blow
out
in enough big states we might need to
tell people that look it's better for us
to be right than fast
there's also this thing called the the
blue shift you know about this
no this is where it happened a lot in
2018
where early numbers when we get these
you know early
the early count tends to favor
republicans and then it moves towards
democrats as the later ballots are
counted for whatever reason maybe they
vote more by mail or they make up their
mind later or whatever
so you could get a thing where president
trump you know looks like he's up in by
30 000 votes in florida
and he says i've won florida i've won
the election
no matter what the networks say if that
say
that just made that up at florida
pennsylvania whatever puts him over and
then when the
other votes for biden start trickling in
and he maybe didn't win that state he
can say hey
that's fraud oh absolutely
and you know you could you could
absolutely see something like that
happening and
and the fact that the president has
already
talked about a rigged election and and
talked about
what he sees as the potential for fraud
and these mail-in ballots
um and you know if you want a job
right now the best job is to be an
election lawyer because both sides
are lawyering up and you know going to
have in any
closely contested state we'll have
lawyers there you know with the
equivalent of the hanging chads we may
have lawyers
watching election people days after the
election
count counting ballots and you can be
sure whichever side
is losing in the that late count is
going to raise issues about it so so
and that that's very much concerns me
we're not talking about a city council
in uh in pittsburgh we're talking about
the most important job in the world
and you know if we're two three four
days
past the election and one side seemed to
have won it
but in fact they haven't you know the
the potential for disruption
i mean you know frankly i've thought
about this and and i kind of hope it is
a blowout one way or the other
i don't care who's winning but you would
like on election night for it to be
really clear
that candidate a is the president and
candidate be lost
and hopefully they both act responsibly
and uh
the country is able to move on all right
from your lips chris wallace
uh host of fox news sunday we'll talk to
you soon buddy thank you very much
you bet thank you chris
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever changing times
you can rely on fox news for hourly
updates for the very latest news and
information
on your time listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
the transportation security
administration which works to keep
millions of travelers safe each day
is showing some love to its canine
agents it's holding a contest to see
which of its working
dogs is the cutest the contest is a
run-up to national dog day later this
month
the pups aren't mascots they're trained
to detect explosive materials
something the tsa describes as the
greatest threat to the aviation system
the tsa says it has more than a thousand
explosive detection canine teams
the dogs and their handlers screen
passengers cargo
mass transit and other systems the
contestants were nominated by tsa
handlers across the country
and the results have been narrowed down
to four voting for the contest is
underway on the tsa's twitter
facebook and instagram accounts the top
dog will be announced on national dog
day which is august 26th
tanya j powers fox news
it's time for your fox news commentary
jason chaffetz
what's on your mind with less than three
months until the 2020 election and no
end in sight for the coronavirus
pandemic
a new debate over mail-in voting has
begun
swirling and sudden concerns about the
united states postal service have
arisen from the democrats who are wildly
accusing
donald trump of cheating and
manipulating the postal service in his
favor
conveniently they forget to mention the
president is more than an arm's length
away from
how we vote and the postal service is
not under the thumb of his control
senate democrats joined republicans to
unanimously install postal leadership
of which one is an obama appointee
no doubt president trump has expressed
deep concerns about the validity of
ballots
and rightfully so sending out millions
of ballots without
authenticating the inbound ballots is
right for massive fraud
it must be noted elections in the united
states are administered by counties and
certified by states
in other words per the united states
constitution elections are run
locally and not by the executive branch
of the federal government
the president has simply sought fair
elections
ironically it is house speaker nancy
pelosi's
hr1 that seeks to federalize elections
and give the president power
he doesn't currently have now her
solution would create the problem
she inaccurately blames trump for today
the president of the united states does
not control the operations of the postal
service
nor does he select or appoint the
postmaster general
the board of governors does both of
these things
the postal regulatory commission sets
rates
service levels and decides on postal
closings
not the president the governors are
appointed by a president
and confirmed by the united states
senate no more than
five of the nine governors may be from
the same political party
robert duncan now serves as the chairman
of the board of governors
from 2007 to 2009 he was the chairman of
the republican national committee
which will undoubtedly be repeated
extensively by
democrats also notable was duncan's
reappointment to the board of governors
in 2019
when the united states senate
unanimously confirmed him again
89 to nothing it will be difficult for
the democrats with a straight face
to complain about duncan's leadership
when the senate confirmed him a second
time
and did so unanimously the governors
are accomplished members of the business
community and largely
not overtly political the inspector
general is
also appointed by the board of governors
and not by the president of the united
states
the current inspector general is tammy
whitcomb
further the chairman of the postal
regulatory commission the prc
robert taub was appointed by president
obama and confirmed unanimously by voice
vote in the united states senate in
december 2016.
if there is a short fall in service it
isn't the president who is in charge
the board of governors and the postal
rate commission make the decisions
the united states postal service
receives no annual appropriation
by the united states congress their
operating budget is dictated by their
revenue which has fallen precipitously
with electronic communications the
pulsar service
offers a variety of products and
services pay for first-class mail
and you get faster service pay for bulk
mail and you get much slower service
it's been that way for a long long time
it's not something president
trump conjured up to manipulate the
election
and pelosi and schumer know it i'm jason
chaffetz former chairman of the
oversight and government reform
committee
and a fox news contributor
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
it's the latest from fox news podcasts
the campaign with breadbear with
updates from reporters on the trail and
in studio experts brett keeps you
informed on the 2020 race go to
foxnewspodcast.com and download the
campaign with bret bear now
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes